[Music]
all right so we in the middle of a
pandemic we
are not traveling as much or are we
i'm here in l.a so i cannot talk about
that i've traveled here
i went to a casino you went to a casino
i went with you
oh where'd you go to a casino uh vegas
vegas yeah also
viejas yeah we we've done a couple of
road trips yesterday we went to the red
rock casino
and it was [ __ ] lit and this is why i
have a mask on uh-huh
you guys are awesome can i give you a
[ __ ] hug right now no
what you don't you're against love he
hates hugs man you choose corona
overlapping
nelson hates hugs nelson is a hug hater
hug
hater when it comes to traveling what
dictates
how you choose your destinations at this
road trip road trips
i'm down for road trips i do not like
being stuck in an airplane with other
people would you rather be in a closed
environment where everyone's breathing
together well a close environment with
people that i know people huh with
fellow quarantine people yes
i like new things new experiences being
in an enclosed space with strangers
breathing the same air that they breathe
even though they have [ __ ] hepa
purifiers whatever
just to translate for nelson he said
that he likes nude things nude
experiences
i thought that was really good can you
please be his translator because we've
filmed all day
i can't hear you i know i'm wrong no no
i got your bike but you're
my man and i got a horny dude is he
likes to be nude that's fine
i'm down with that i felt like kind of a
diva when i said i only wanted to fly
like jet suite which is smaller
the the system itself is different i
didn't have to go through like the big
crowded
it is cheaper now cheaper i do go to
burbank
i love it but i feel maybe it's a false
sense of security because it is less
people and the process is not as crowded
as going through an airport
burbank you might as well be socially
distanced the whole [ __ ] time there's
like
no there's no one there there and that's
that's how and you just walk on a tarmac
too you don't do tsa
you don't have to do anything about the
seating arrangements the seating
situations for the most part there is
there was space this last flight i took
oh god
the last flight i took it's only an hour
so it's not that bad but
there was somebody next to me i feel
uncomfortable with people sitting next
to
me
it doesn't mask and everything i still
feel uncomfortable uh
because the pandemic has made me very
aware of space
so so what's so cool about the pandemic
for me
is that i hate sitting next to people
that i don't know and so i feel like
this is going to remedy that
we're forever we won't have the sentence
to people we don't know like that in the
movie theaters i wanna
i wanna never have to sit next to people
either i wanna talk to people
i mean but you don't feel that like on a
financial side that they're not going to
try to put as many people as they can on
a plane to go and make up for all the
money that they've been losing that's
right are you gonna buy i
might get less leg room i saw somebody
buy
a couple buy a whole rope damn because
the planes are starting to fill back up
because remember the
the money that the airline company's got
is gone now so they have to go and make
their money
back but i'd seen like a lot of the
planes are starting to get fuller again
i don't like it i will pay now for my
spa
for my space and i don't think that
airlines are going to accommodate that
no way i mean they won't accommodate
their employees this way they just laid
off a bunch of [ __ ] people
and then even just throughout the years
like without the pandemic in the
equation they have just
constantly been reconfiguring the
airplanes themselves to fit more and
more people yeah it's been
way overkill way overkill there's no
reason why you have to have people
sitting spirit airlines y'all are trash
[ __ ] airlines and then they go and they
charge you for breathing like they
charge you extra
for you even took spirit i have a [ __ ]
has been broke before no shame
allegiance that's why we be flying jsx
and i'll be
spending extra for the first class i
like remember allegiant
we got our whole company trip going to
hawaii because we could afford it that
way
i mean 200 dollars round trip yeah but
we had like a [ __ ] three hour la
uh a delay waiting for [ __ ] ice what
was the food service on allegiance
exactly you can't even recline your seat
no yeah
i mean yeah you're on a budget you got
to fly budget no yeah
like i said i've i've been there i've
done that dude aren't allegiant do they
throw the pretzels at you they're just
like i don't even think they have they
charge you twelve dollars for pretzels
that's how the scene hey here's your
pretzels [ __ ]
ow i guess thank you i really believe
that that those budget airlines
ultimately
are actually more expensive yeah you
have to pay for the inconvenience of
your time you have to pay for the
inconvenience of like just
comfort itself and then your baggage
there's no there's no benefit or
purchase you're more expensive to fly
but you know what that's what they do
with a lot of knockoff or discount
things they fool
people into thinking that this is better
for them that's the whole concept boost
mobile oh same [ __ ] metropcs
[Applause]
okay that's all don't be touching but i
feel you though i feel you so this one
has nothing to do with
airplanes more about tourism and then
traveling
have you guys heard of heat tourism
before no
tourism to experience weather that's
different from your own
yes oh is it like extremely different
hold on did you
know that before or was this happening
he's a very smart person
no i've gathered that is it like with
the mask on yeah from cold climates and
then they run away from the winter to go
to like hot
places you're going south for the winter
yeah it's like in um hawaii right like
on maui like a lot of canadians go there
during the winter yeah oh it's sure
mexico too a lot of people a lot of
alaskans um
travel to like florida oh true but what
you guys are saying actually makes
way more sense and seems like it's an
enjoyable
thing what heat tourism in this context
is
people driving thousands of miles to
nevada's
death valley oh no for a selfie with a
thermometer that's so hot though
first off if you stupid enough to drive
anywhere for a damn selfie and you ain't
getting no likes or no money off of it
you better change your damn
life because you're [ __ ] up i just
drove there it was a hundred and ten
when i touched the window i was like ah
but it was like for myself
no no we were driving through death
valley is different than
two 110 though is different from say 1
30. look at this girl of course this
one's going to check it so check it out
samantha looking at
oh he tourism is to get the selfie with
it
stupid so people are traveling to death
valley specifically for
this thermometer but the two don't even
work it's so high i know
there's where's the it's so hot it was
like [ __ ] i don't even want to be here
true dude some people would actually go
to the surface of venus
he looks like he's [ __ ] dying look at
his see-through shirt from this
sweat that's all that hold on wait
please scroll through and show us all
the people that decided
i hadn't seen that photo because you
keep going through and he was like it's
not sweat it's just
water are we catching a pattern survive
are we catching a powder
stupid people all these stupid people
you thought i was going to say something
i was gonna you weren't
you're gonna join them i thought you're
gonna say very people who get
lots of tans oh yeah tan people go very
tan people
that one guy had a tan on his forehead
or it was sunburned
true so is this becoming like going to a
national oh it is a national park yeah
[Applause]
i had to look it's like this like do we
know if these are fans of the wwe
character the undertaker
i do not know because he is from death
valley
or is his character from death valley
well of course his character
mark calloway is not from death valley
is that why when he came out fire would
come out yeah he's like you guys can
feel what i feel
exactly you know what the crazy part
about character development oh yeah he's
he's the best ever you know what the
crazy part about this whole thing is
people are actually parked in the the
parking lot at death valley national
park
waiting for the thermometer to go to 1
30. if it's not 1 30 people are staying
inside the cars waiting
waiting until it hits 1 30. and when a
hit does it 1 30. oh my god
everyone jumps out of the car to flock
to the [ __ ] thermometer to take a
picture 129 is not sexy 127 is not sexy
is 130 like the hottest it can get yeah
that's that's like the record
temperature like everybody's
goal and weight like i just want to be
130. this is the only time i'm ever
gonna see 130 in front of me so i'm
going to stand by it
no recently the that thermometer broke
like the
the all-time the all-time like from
since the beginning of recording
temperature in death valley recently
they broke the record i think it was
like 137 or something
yeah you know what bothers me about this
is that yeah there's a number
on the screen but you don't really like
me looking at it
i'm not catching like oh it's really hot
out you can't it's the hottest place on
earth
on earth they should cook something on
like i think
that's better proof that's better right
because standing next to this like
i'm not impressed by any one of them
standing next to that that guy's body
was clicking though
yeah you can kind of see how they're
like i'm not surprised to see a fat
person sweat though
that's true it's not that crazy you made
the point of them being really tan they
all
look like they've been in tanning beds
for a long time they've been training
for this moment their whole life yeah
that's kind of what the tan people do
california and knowing that that center
is in california where it's only four
hours away yeah it's like on the border
of california nevada
the hottest place on
earth really entire planet that is the
hottest place on earth
and it's in the state of california it's
only four hours away
i am like i'm kind of proud of that
i was waiting to see where you were
going to go with it you're like i'm
proud of my
problem i want to go there and feel what
130 i feel like you have to cook
something in order for it to be an egg
period even in the sauna
like at 120 yeah yeah i'm already like i
can't breathe
i'd rather feel the coldest place in the
hottest place that's me first of all i
know
i'm going like yeah i'd rather be in
cold yeah but then still i still need to
feel it
i'm going hotter than colder i would
rather be colder because i could bundle
up yeah for me
i got i got achy i got achy joints so
oh so cold [ __ ] cold hurts yeah my mom
broke her leg she has a pole in her
thigh oh she hates the people she she
hates the cold hates the cold
why because it freezes her she can feel
her metal pull thing
when you when you have a lot of energy
when you have a lot of injuries
it hurts like cold hurts like it tenses
all your muscles and everything
mm-hmm oh my back started hurting just
thinking about i was like oh my god
yeah but yeah the metal probably gets
cold too [ __ ] yeah and she's like
there's going to be a thunderstorm today
i'm like you're a [ __ ] crackpot and
then there's a thunderstorm
cause she's like a weather rock yeah
dude she's got like some kind of tingles
like the mean girls like with their
boobs
yeah i go she's like my titties are
telling me there's gonna be a hurricane
oh my god okay
if you have curly hair you know when
it's going to rain oh because it just
can sense the humidity in the hair
oh really because like it's freezing up
yeah my hair can be straight and then
it'll start to expand and i'm like oh
we're going to get rain
maybe my antennas are growing for
something get it
i wonder what i can sense probably hard
dicks
but what if that was like oh oh no so
you're so hard right now bro why
i didn't know what are you doing oh man
you didn't tell me are you getting a tub
dude i'm sorry i tried to touch you so
many times in this video what is that
fish called
with the thing fish ready to pick up
some girls
in a light bulb but you only find hard
[ __ ] i know god damn it
[ __ ] this thing look at the ladies
things suck broken for some reason it
was so hard too
god damn it yeah but fun fact uh in the
past seven years since
the popularity of instagram there's only
one like on that photo these people are
wasting their
time they are not worthy of this photo
yes there's only one life
you are a forensic instagram expert no
right
you're wasting your damn time people no
you know what though i bet you
those people are kind of like what i do
which is it's the experience
of it that's what i care most about and
then the only reason i post it on
instagram
is not because of the followers i have
it's because i want to remember the
experience true well let me tell you
a l underscore just style in los
angeles you better go and start
advertising if your
ass is gonna stand in 130 degree heat
for instagram and get one like at least
you could have got your mama to like
your damn picture that's probably who it
was
burned you got burned and then you got
burned 130 degrees you got roasted and
then you got roasted there's one
like on this damn photo i cannot
maybe it was a fresh photo how many
people are in this room if i post a
stupid photo with 130 degrees all y'all
better like it i will take
four likes six i don't know i will
i take my life very seriously well
clearly none of his friends care about
him that much
unless he has one friend it was one of
the your father hold on wait if your
mom liked the photo then your dad didn't
like it you only got one damn
cold world hate each other you know what
your back story is not something i want
to hear they just left each other's
photos what happened
you stood next to a 130 degree [ __ ]
sign you better get all them damn likes
just shop it i would just shop it and
move on the lakes
chop the [ __ ] ones no i take a
picture next to 77 degrees and then shop
it to once so that makes more sense yeah
i'm out of there i'm out of there
pee shopping yeah i could do it with one
like if it's photoshopped but like they
stood outside for that
nothing they drove all the way there and
why are they so happy and so this this
thing like
i don't know i'd be like don't touch me
yeah it's hot dude
this morning it was so hot i'm like
nikki don't touch me i know it's way too
hot
don't worry i won't
[Music]
you